[Music]
yo what's up welcome to this week's
winners on a Wednesday amazing beautiful
ladies on the show they are financially
free they have done some training with
us and they've been watching my youtube
videos forever and now that's that how's
it feel to be on the other end of the
screen on folks they were really good I
think a little bit unbelievable well are
actually here yeah when did you first
decide that you wanted to get into
property in handa happen so what was it
but six months ago yeah okay yeah um
about I think so my little boys dad had
the into the DfE and he told me about he
told me all about it the VIP training
program DfE trainer phone yeah yeah and
I had like no ideas of my property
whatsoever I was always in the corporate
world so property was totally new and he
just said I think you would be really
good at this I think I should go and
that was in February so we registered
for their crash course in Birmingham and
that was June and I think from then
weenus knew this was for us at the crash
course yeah months ago yeah what you've
achieved in the last few months is just
insane I think you've just gone at it
guns blazing and you guys are sisters
yeah from Island beautiful accent so ok
so give me the backstories then like you
guys were stupid corporate world I
walked in barfi card so I handed in my
notice after the crash course that was
they literally came to the press wasn't
handling you know yeah that in faith it
was up because you found so many good
deals well a bit of folks and I just
wasn't happy there
I've looked at Gareth she's three and
she was in nursery long hours yeah so I
was just fed up a little talk
and we know what was it at the crash
course what was it that gave you that um
or inspiration to quit we just knew we
could do it didn't we yeah we knew
because we were finding deals and
on the crash course so I hate the energy
in the room as well we come out like
feeling electric and pom through like if
any of all these people can do it
because I think there was some previous
Academy members up in the stage and yeah
we just thought well if they can do it
why can't we
yeah and it was just as as simple as
that that's so cool that's so cool okay
so you came to the crash course in
February was he February to June your
husband or partner so no he hated the
deal finding extravaganza in February
yes then you came to the crash course in
June and you were like boom let's do
this yeah so what happened then and we
signed up for the Academy on the first
day good for you before the day even
ended we went and tried to capture
Alistair somewhere in the room yeah we
want to do this by myself and then we
started our launch pad on the 31st of
July yeah which is only a couple of
weeks ago yeah we're not a couple of
weeks yes well eight weeks yeah come on
a month couple of months yeah and since
then it's just been a whirlwind yeah
being so hectic Kathryn yeah i'm when we
were in there at the rent rent of course
of course the first call I made
regarding a deal and lead or successful
and we signed up and I do you that was a
cross scorning elevator yeah so all
right you guys have you guys got like
this magical Midas touch on yet like how
you go to the crash course and you find
a bunch of deals you join the Academy
you then start the academy training on
the on the first day you whenever it was
on the on this is like a four day course
isn't it so you say yeah you find a lead
that turns into a deal like what are you
doing what do you think there's magic
what's the difference between you guys
that have been successful I know I want
to talk about some of your deals because
I know they're really profitable but
what's the difference between you guys
because there's other people that might
watch the videos on what want to be
property investor they might even come
to the crash course and they aren't
successful what's the difference you
think I think you need to be brave
and I think you need to be out of your
own comfort zone yeah it's not easy you
know every day is exciting nervous
challenging all enrolled off in the one
feeling strange yeah and but it just
pushes you to keep going I think you
need to have that maybe it's a hunger
and a desire to do well yeah and just
not giving up constantly ringing and
ringing and ringing it yeah yeah because
even though we got loads of gnomes after
the first year yeah and we just never
really give up and kept ringing and read
yeah that's great
that's the persistence is so important I
mean dr. John Demartini says that you're
you're always gonna have challenges
you're either gonna have challenges that
inspire you or you're gonna have
challenges that don't inspire you and
it's best to sit yourself Charlie does
it inspire you and I think you guys have
been working so hard the last few months
and you've had massive challenges but
you've been growing in that yeah and and
that's been so incredibly just to see
your growth journey I mean talk to me
about that I think where we are now
compared to eight or nine weeks ago is
it's completely completely different so
we started off not so much nervous
making the calls but that confidence has
just grown a relationship with so many
people know in in Manchester and
agencies who I suppose you could say
they're like friends yeah relationship
now with people like contacting us yeah
and I think making the relationships
personable like this the first agency
that we dealt with we spoke to her about
our family she was a lovely lady and we
had last a similarity she had young
children so did we and like everybody
says at the people game and it really is
yeah it really really is you've both got
kids
and families and u-boat sisters right
what's the strongest reason he doing
this is if you kids what's the real with
hunger behind what he wanted to do this
I'd say a person for me and is most of
it is for my little girl specially
because she was a nursery from like 7:00
in the morning till sometimes 6:00 in
the evening it was long and but then
[Music]
it's just a walking thing as well I
don't want to work for somebody anyone
during the one nine to five or seven to
five hours anymore it is it's time isn't
it that's much again flexibility being
able to kind of do what you want to do
yeah yeah talk to me about the first
deal though so you're on the Your Honor
Academy regiment training yeah make a
call
how did you find me how did you find the
seller really nice yeah so I rang the
guy and I could tell he was driving and
I just said look of senior property
online and I'd love to get a view in but
just before I okay like I want me to let
you know that I'm interested in short
term let's it's not something that
you're comfortable with or after hair
effects before and he was rushed because
I could tell he was driving it was more
like a yeah okay that's fine that's fine
that's fine but I thought was he just
trying to get me off the phone here yeah
and so I called him back later on just
to make sure everything was okay and he
caught me in touch with his agency who
manages property yeah and we booked an
appointment for nine o'clock on the
Monday morning so we left London on
Sunday and at nine o'clock on Monday
morning we went to the property for the
viewing you guys you guys are from
living in Manchester I mean in my time
but you were in London for the course
yes and you literally went straight from
the red to red course to the viewing on
Monday morning yeah
insane and then what happened well we
were really lucky that we went at nine
o'clock because somebody asked from the
Academy had also picked interview and oh
that was a huge lesson for us I was like
the biggest s and I've taken is that if
you see a good deal
need to take it quick yes you don't
someone else is going to come behind you
and take it
Wow yeah and a bet the other recovery
member they yeah yeah that's how we are
yeah we're not a girl we're not
collaborative if someone beats us to a
deal and we just go Fairplay man you got
there yeah okay so did you both go
together to the viewing yeah and then
how did you feel it do you think I'm
gonna get this deal we were thinking
this is ours we're getting this yeah
that's it
so how much weight did you agree to pay
their animals it was them really really
low around north and 450 pounds I was
where I was that it's a one-bedroom
apartment just they say to Manchester
okay one-bedroom apartment just does a
lot of Manchester he talked to me about
the compliance and the paperwork and
getting all that sorted what are the
things you have to do with the landlord
yeah so with the land it was quite good
cuz there was two of us yeah W double
teamed in right yeah the landlord had
never ever heard of like short cameras
before he had really had no idea and
there were a little bit nervous but we
just convinced him that we want to look
after the property we have cleaners in
place like we felt like we were
completely blagging it but we obviously
came across really really well we were
nervous we were just have to even be we
you just got back off the call yeah you
hadn't even had time to go home and
sleep and here you are with this land no
guns oh here's what we do those are
questions that access is where we were
kind of just winging it where we oh yeah
like what I can't even remember but what
stop the said to us and we're just
agreeing with them different things I
can't remember exactly but we were just
being confident yes it was clear - did
they didn't really know too much about
what we were talking about yeah we just
went in the bottom line is that although
you know why you didn't know it you you
know know everything yeah about
everything unless you've done it
and without trying new
and as you guys know because you've been
on it we're very much a case of like
book the viewings just just do it yeah
and we try and give you enough to be
able to get a deal but when it comes to
all the XYZ ed stuff and as you've heard
me say I'll say walk the ABC yeah and
then figure out the XYZ if you've done
the training you've spent thousands of
pounds getting this training you've got
the support group you've got other
people or ahead of you that you can call
yeah you know so you've got that within
the academy just go and do it
so that's you know that's awesome that
you just went out and did that so you
kind of figure it out as we went along
yes and then presumably had to ask a lot
of questions for all the people on the
Academy oh so what I don't what what
happen there there was we had so many
questions and I began it at the
beginning I was using the Facebook
Academy page yeah all the time I
remember saying that
because we were just because we were
Australian at the door from the trade
and yeah we still had a lot of questions
about you know getting set off flying
just all the the usual questions that
you would have yeah and but it was great
because that's that first deal that we
got was quite straightforward for us
well it wasn't too challenging but we
were scared obviously going through it
yeah but it's taught us so much and it
kind of prepared us for what was what
was to come
yes what's the next one with that
property then is that live now yeah so
you got the keys you secured it you've
now got it it's live taking bookings
yeah that's amazing so fast and how much
I knew it's very early days but you say
like how was the when did since it went
live how are the bookings that the
coming in what's it looking like what
are you expected to make profit each
month from that one deal that particular
one between five and six hundred pound a
month that's really good yeah that's
really good you can have very Google
conservative based on what the bottom to
be and it was that one was really what
we would see is a low-risk lot of work
to do the ramp was slow and for the
first kind of deal that we got it was
perfect for us how much did you have to
put down on that deal and we just paid
one month rent upfront yeah and we got
the keys two weeks early yeah to go
don't read it and get it ready did you
decorate it yourself yes and yes how
much did all that cost because there's
only a one bedroom it wasn't too much so
probably very open to pain yeah wasn't
much of a pound that's not bad I guess
when you're doing yourself yeah and you
live quite close by right yeah and so
that's that's fantastic that's just
that's that's like a perfect little deal
isn't emu first deal yeah I always say
whenever you you first deals always your
hardest and you're probably gonna make
mistakes so it's good to start with a
small deal because then if you make
mistakes it's not too it's not too
costly then you pay one rent one month's
rent up for it you buy into pound you
know two or three grand all-in I which
is that about what it was absolutely to
then make five 600 pound profit a month
that's a really nice little rent to rent
deal yeah so what happened after that
then see did that give you confidence
when you got that one yeah then we're
like right okay on to the next one
yeah and then what happened we got we
were ringing and ringing and we got the
lead from what she got the lead from
Gumtree yeah well I don't think you got
a call for like a couple of days later
and but it was like from we got the keys
on the Monday and then we got another
lead for another apartment in the city
centre and that was on the tourists it
like a couple of days later a couple of
days later then so we went in and viewed
that one and there was back then there
was like air available no initially
there was only so what happened was
there was I saw a lead on gumtree for
one apartment and I was in work I was
still working at the time and I Ryan KD
straight away and I said I've just seen
an amazing apartment in the city centre
it's brand new we need to go see it so I
rang yeah and we got a viewing for about
an hour later and I left work I said I
have to go I have to leave Wow and they
were like they were cool with it so we
went and when we were named we found out
the words I think there was five at the
time available and we just said
straightaway we'll take them all of them
we didn't know how we're gonna take them
yeah but we were taking them
yeah and because there were we knew the
location was brilliant
there were brand-new the rubble of
departments who knew the area very well
and we knew they'd work and then we went
after viewing them straight to the
office with the agent after the viewing
yeah and we paid our Holden pilot how
did you pay afford it I had a credit
card
oh that is brave mm-hmm taking four
apartments so on with a credit card I
mean that's pretty brave okay and that
worked out I mean yeah it's been a
journey because we initially secured
four and then the landlord offered us
three more which we were initially want
to take yeah and we thought maybe we're
taking on a bit to March but we can
handle it you know you do it and then it
turned out the one of the apartments and
was taken off market right there was a
one-bedroom one which and wasn't really
as lucrative as the other ones after
checking their DNA so you know you know
how to work out your due diligence early
research absolutely she's really
important absolutely
it's not just a case of getting the
getting Adira to get a good deal yeah
and then the was there - there's another
two-bedroom but their floor plan was
different to what they had advised I
said it was and they just went of work
right yeah yeah so we sat was on four
yeah and we've got four they're up and
running they went live on Tuesday that's
so cool and have you got bookings coming
in yeah over our 50 Buchan so far oh my
goodness in what four days yeah fifty
buckins yeah um what's the average room
rate per night and the average is a
hundred 143 pounds a week and every
weekend is bricked up until far one
until the end of November
alrighty so how much profit then are you
expected to make after you know all you
do diligence you research looking at
what bookings are coming in how much
profit how many partners have you gotten
to help five how much will they make you
on average per month roughly about seven
and a half
I found that's so good how do you feel
it's just unreal it's unbelievable we
really can't believe it but like with
Pinterest ABS every day don't mckiddy
they gave them under way of coming down
here today we're like we always said
from the crash course we would be on -
Wednesday we yeah it's going to happen
it's just a matter of when
yes but we didn't think it would be this
soon but we did put everything into it
like we put our heart and soul into
making this work but still three months
you came on the crash course was it but
was this June in October July August
took for four months yeah - making like
seven and a half thousand pound profit a
month it's just ridiculous yeah I know
so what's been the biggest what's been
the biggest takeaways um I think for us
is that it's just opened a whole new
world for us yeah that anything is
possible now yeah cuz we've proven to
ourselves that we're pretty pretty good
at doing it you're very good and you
know we can only get better and grow if
we're doing this well so soon you know
how much better can we do have you made
a lot of friends on the academy yeah
loads yeah talk to me about that it's
we've got a little and Manchester
mastermind that's that great because
when we were at the the Academy there's
so many people from Manchester yeah
honest so we all joined up and connected
and so it's good just chatting to them
bear claw please but sometimes it's not
even about fluffy just how's everybody
goin how's everybody doing yeah I need
to keep in contact with them all isn't
it and then we've got a group as well
and it's the poor group that we keep in
touch with yeah and that's over the last
eight weeks we've been so busy and we
like like I think it was last week we
even apologized to the group because
we've not been you know given as much
information as we normally would because
we've just been so crazy yeah but we
started updating each other now we've
made it really oh I see all the time on
the growth I see you guys posting
pictures and they look all the way they
look fabulous
your the way you've done them out
you've you've done them really high-end
maybe on budget but they look really
nice and you've really utilized all the
you know the every every everything only
you haven't even down to support groups
and the people and the training you've
been at everything which is fantastic
what's next then what's what's the plan
for they because you built the Academy
two months like he doesn't like a lot
more training to get through and all
kinds of different types of property
investment so what's next is awesome
yeah we're fully complying for dear
source and now we've already got a
couple of investors who are in dress and
walk with us yeah and they're looking
for like HMOs and yeah I think now that
were confident that we've got some cash
flow coming in from the apartments yes
we're gonna we've got the Train in next
month was training India next month
we're on DFA next month yeah and then
you do it infinite returns yes okay
that's gonna be good yes we're excited
for that and we think it's probably
perfect timing as we move strategy a
little bit onto the deal sourcing yes so
we're probably couldn't come at a better
time for us night yeah yeah were you
nervous before doing the Academy I know
you signed up on day one and you
accepted on which is fantastic but did
you come knowing that you do that or did
you come and then did you just think
right I mean what happened I think we
were there I was there for about an hour
and I said Emma I'm signing up and I
just said yeah we are we're doing this
boy which is crazy I think it's you know
it's hard to know what to expect before
you get to the crash course yeah yeah we
didn't really know what was gonna come
from it I was gonna be but it was quick
it like it was a back within an hour
look what was your experience at the
crash course like I always said the
energy we think that's really important
and just meeting somewhere deeper
yeah we were talking to people from all
over the UK that we've never normally
you know chat to and talk to yeah and
then to see here when you talk with the
opportunities and how simple it was that
was what I was really frustrated at
myself thinking how can this be so
simple and how do I not know about these
things
I don't I have a got to this stage in my
life where I could have
be doing these things before I just
never knew yeah and I think you kind of
have this idea that properly invest in
oh that's got me and women need lots of
money it's coming really difficult
because that's kind of what I didn't
think and I've always been interested in
property but then coming to the crash
course and we arising okay I can
actually do this that was like it was a
change me completely really did that's
great because I think a lot of people
every month you put it off you
potentially losing seven and a half
grand a month yeah you know are you
still working you quit work I'll quit
did you yeah what did you quit
Barclaycard
oh yeah I think you mention you quit are
used to working no I I left my job as
well you two were just like unstoppable
man when when did you quit and my last
day was the 16th of September oh yeah
September yeah please interact what day
it is I know yeah but I mean that's
insane sometimes people you know people
think it's just too good to be true
you know I mean obviously you got it's
possible because you guys have seen
people do it you've been followed it's
worked out for you the money's in the
coming in your back pills why you've now
quit your jobs yeah you've not got lots
of savings that you're eating out of
yeah it's just literally the money that
you've made from property like what
would you say to people that just think
I cannot believe that it sounds too good
to be true what would you say it's
definitely true hundred percent if we
can do it like we've got small children
I was working a full-time job with a
little boy as well and Katie okay you
need to put the work and you need to
find the time to make it happen yeah I
think if you're hungry enough for it it
would work yeah I think you need to win
100 percent what do you think stops most
people from being successful in this
industry or people that want to do it
but never quite it's tough I won't even
notice I'm not sure maybe some people
don't have the support like we had each
other we had yeah that's the crash
course or you're on the Academy we had
the support of everybody
yeah well we got some ideas know each
other was really good yeah some days
we'd have like a bad day or we'd have
loads
and one day and then we feel about
deflated but then she might ring me and
she'd be all excited yes so then that
bring me back up or face fair so it was
happened in both of us so we always had
each other kind of - what's the Academy
been like I love it I'd like we feel
like it's like a little holiday for us
because we've got young children we
cannot wait now to go and see all our
friends in November yeah on the trailer
yeah like the kids are sorted everything
so we can't wait yeah you know it's
amazing what we all best piece of advice
to someone who's watching this to do
right now if they're watching this what
should they do just pick on a crash
course just go and see for yourself
and I think invest in yourself is like
the biggest lesson what do you mean
invest in yourself just learning there's
so much you can there and yeah and
anything is possible if you have the
right tools and that's something that
you've given us and the Academy has
given us if the tools to do the job yeah
it's that simple yeah I know you give us
you give somebody yes we wouldn't have
been able to get as far as we have so
quickly whatever well I'm amazed at how
well you've done and I'm looking forward
to continuing to get to know you guys on
the more training so thank you ever so
much for coming down from Manchester to
Shane story and what's one last question
though what's next what's the next I
mean you mentioned deal sourcing yeah
what do you want people did what - I
mean how can happen people are cheering
you on because you can have thousands of
people watching this Academy and there's
what can we do to help you even go to
the next level I think for us it's just
you know supporting us on our journeys
the next stage for us is we want to
start packaging deals for ambassadors
right we want to become investors
ourselves yeah and that's that's our
next okay well I thoroughly endorse you
guys so if you're watching this and
you're looking for deal I can just
these guys have got great energy they're
great at talking with people and with
the training you're gonna get next month
as well on that side of things you're
gonna absolutely kill it so if you've
been watching this and you've been
putting things off whether it's booking
onto the crash course whether it's
picking up the phone and phoning
floating their landlord what I would say
is just what stop what you're doing and
just do it right now as we speak if you
haven't had success also by being on the
training program you
come to the crash course and you'll find
actually free and I don't know you or
you haven't told us please do get in
touch I've looked at you invite you down
to the offices as well because we've got
so many amazing stories that are coming
up it's sometimes hard to keep track so
thanks for watching the video please do
subscribe
[Music]